Schultern sie noch mal die Frage ich
habe das vorhin kurz zitiert sie haben
11 Prozent
Arbeitslosigkeit in Bremen im Land ja im
Land genau
Viertel mit
25% zum Teil und was auffällt in dieser
Statistik ist sehr viele
Langzeitarbeitslose signifikant hohe
Anteil und des Rücken nach signifikant
viele Schulabbrecher
Frage setzen wir die falschen Anreize
lohnt es sich in diesem Land noch zu
arbeiten wie erklären Sie sich das na
klar lohnt es sich in diesem Land zu
arbeiten und wir haben ja in Bremen ein
ungeheuren Aufbau an Beschäftigung in
den letzten Jahren gehabt wir haben ja
viele viele tausend Arbeitsplätze
geschaffen und es gab noch nie ein so
hohes Beschäftigungsniveau in Bremen wie
in Deutschland insgesamt wie wir das im
Moment haben ab wie vielen
30.000 Arbeitslosen und 8000 freie
Stellen und
30.000 8.000 freie Stellen 30.000 und
wir haben natürlich ein starkes was
sagen die Fachleute matching Problem das
heißt die Qualifikation
derjenigen die
arbeitslos sind und die Anforderungen
der Stellen wo finden
das gehört natürlich soweit auch dazu
wir haben natürlich in Bremen eine
extrem hohe Zuwanderung gehabt deutlich
mehr als in allen anderen Bundesländern
vergleichbar wie das in vielen anderen
Großstädten der Fall ist aber sie haben
ja jetzt die Statistik sozusagen auf
Landesebene genannt und da haben wir
natürlich ein extrem hohe Betroffenheit
derjenigen die zugewandert sind von
Arbeitslosigkeit
von von Menschen mit nicht deutschem
Pass in dieser Arbeitslosigkeit
ich würde jetzt mal sagen ungefähr zwei
Drittel der Arbeitslosen haben sozusagen
ein Migrationshintergrund oder
dreiviertel
in Bremen und das ist ja in gewisser
Weise auch nachvollziehbar da fehlt
häufig an Sprachkenntnissen da sind
Leute da sind Leute erst jetzt oder vor
kurzem ins Land gekommen und da Bedarfs
natürlich besondere Anstrengungen und
das fit für den Arbeitsmarkt zu machen
ohne dass das die einzige Problematik
ist aber wir haben diese Problematik die
ist übrigens und das mal zu sagen wer in
den letzten Jahren deutlich weniger
geworden wir hatten mal über 17% oder 17
% Arbeitslosigkeit jetzt
vor der Ukraine Krieg angefangen hat und
viele Menschen dazu gekommen sind
ungefähr zehn Prozent das heißt
das wichtigste was man im Moment
natürlich hinkriegen muss ist die kriegt
man
offenen Jobs und und das ist die große
Frage da kommt auch gleicher Paul ins
Spiel aber wird gern noch mal den sehr
pragmatischen dänischen Ansatz mit ihm
kurz besprechen weil
er wurde gerade gesagt von dem
bodenschulte wir müssen natürlich
erstmal schauen wir müssen die Leute
Sprachkurse müssen sie quasi natürlich
die müssen erstmal langsam irgendwie
sich zurechtfinden und dann bringen wir
sie irgendwann in den Arbeitsmarkt was
zu dem Thema oder zu der zu einem
Umstand führt dass wir jedes Jahr haben
wir Rekord Zuwanderung
und gleichzeitig haben wir ein riesiges
fachkräftethema wir kriegen die Leute
nicht in den Arbeitsmarkt
sie haben irgendwo erzählt im Vorfeld
und das fand ich sehr interessant mit
Blick auf die Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
was in Dänemark grundsätzlich anders
läuft als in Deutschland was
ja also erstmal muss man immer aufpassen
im Vergleich zwischen Dänemark und
Deutschland ist natürlich von der Größe
her aber es geht um den Ansatz absolut
aber man muss trotzdem zwei drei Sätze
um das verständnishalber da gibt es
seine Arbeitslosigkeit insgesamt
unterhalb von 3% 2,2,9 % der ist der
Zustand in Deutschland natürlich ein
Stück weit anders und es ist einfach so
dass der Ansatz dort war als die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine kamen zu sagen
sie müssen sofort im Arbeitsmarkt und
dort werden sie dann auch sprachliche
Kompetenzen bekommen natürlich ist auch
da der Vergleich einmal wichtig in
Dänemark wird den großen Teilen auch
viel Englisch gesprochen in Deutschland
noch in vielen Fällen noch nicht so
ausgeprägt zum einen und zum anderen
aber die Idee war sozusagen die Leute
von Anfang an direkt in den Arbeit
sofort Integration sofort arbeiten
sofortteile der Lösung also was leisten
man ist auch verpflichtet wenn man nach
Dänemark kommt dem Arbeitsmarkt zur
Verfügung zu stehen man kann Kurse
belegen Sprachkurse und ähnliches das
wird auch unterstützen aber man muss
immer Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung stehen
und deswegen relativ Pflicht zu arbeiten
Pflicht sich zu Arbeit zu melden also
man kann ja niemanden der nicht zur
Arbeit geht dazu zwingen aber also ist
ein Unterschied ob man sagt sie müssen
erstmal einen Kurs belegen und das
werden wir keine Kurse anbieten können
dauert das wenn wir dann ein Kurs
anbieten können dann haben wir leider
keinen Kinderbetreuung dann dauert das
wiederum dann sind die Kurse überlegt
oder belegt in Deutschland haben wir
damals ja auch gefragt vor eineinhalb
Jahren wie lange wollen Sie bleiben die
meisten haben geantwortet wollen so
schnell wie möglich nach Hause nach
etwas über ein Jahr ist die ist das
gekippt mehr hinzu wir würden gerne
bleiben jetzt haben wir aber das Problem
dass Menschen die weit über ein Jahr
warten auf einen Kurs oder also nicht
Teil der Lösung und der arbeitstärke
waren natürlich auch mental das
schwierig haben dann wiederum dort
einzusteigen und da erlebt man natürlich
in die in das dänische Modell ein viel
stärkere Integration und das wenn es die
ganze Zeit geschieht ich habe alleine
Schleswig-Holstein jetzt über 6000
Langzeitarbeitslose Ukraine und wir
warten natürlich darauf dass die Kurse
viel sind warum ja weil sie erst die
ganzen Kurse belegen wir haben auch
viele schöne wunderbare Programme auf
runtergebrochen auf kleinen ist das ja
ein gutes der deutsche Ansatz hat
möglicherweise auf die lange Bahn einen
kleinen Vorteil in Dänemark sind es
viele Hilfstätigkeiten einfachere
Aufgaben wo man auch große Probleme hat
Arbeitskräfte überhaupt keine Familie
genauso aber in Deutschland ist der
Ansatz wir können vielleicht wenn wir
sie erst mehr Deutsch beibringen dann
etwas höher qualifiziert einsetzen also
aus der man kann es ist wie eben gesagt
wurde immer ein bisschen schwarz ein
bisschen weiß dabei ich fand allerdings
das Modell sehr charmant dass jemand der
hierher kommt gleich sagen du musst auch
mit unterstützen bringen das was du
kannst Leiste was du kannst und dann
unterstützen wir auch immer ganz kurz
diese diese Pflicht sozusagen sich zur
Arbeit zu melden sagen sie ich stimmt
ich weiß nicht ob die Zahl stimmt lass
dieser Tage das geht nicht jetzt um
Ukraine
Menschen die aus anderen Ländern kommen
nach Dänemark kommen haben dann sehr
schnell die Pflicht 7 und 30 Stunden in
der Woche zu arbeiten und einen dänisch
Kurs zu besuchen das Licht ja also das
zumindest das Modell von früher was ich
kenne ist ja auch dass man eine
Aufstufung dessen was man Unterstützung
bekommt dann bekommt wenn man einen Kurs
belegt erfolgreich dann hat man auch
einen Anspruch auf mehr Geld und was
wenn derjenige diejenige nicht macht was
passiert dann hat derjenige der deutlich
geringeren Anspruch und muss von sich
aus überlegen aber mit dem deutlich
geringer Geld
aber hier haben wir die Situation wenn
man dann Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung kommt
dann davon nicht arbeiten solange man da
drin ist
das nicht der Fall aber bei anderen bei
anderen die Asylbewerber Verfahren sind
und dann erst Aufnahme Richtung kommen
die dürfen nicht arbeiten das finde ich
übrigens eine Sache wo man dringend
gucken muss im Rahmen in Zeiten von
fachgerechtigung
genau das bestehende Sachen es
interessant ist wissen sie auch wenn man
auch nicht arbeiten darf wenn man aus
einem sicheren Herkunftsland kommt aber
jetzt die Liste sich in Herkunftsländer
aussehen würde dann würde man die Zeile
Leute die nicht arbeiten dürfen wenn ihr
das Asylverfahren würde man noch mal
vergrößern ich finde ja genau meine
Haltung ist wer hierher kommt sollte
sich möglichst schnell nützlich machen
und arbeiten dürfen und
rechtliche Hindernisse die dem
entgegenstehen da muss man noch mal
genauer hinkommen da ist ja viel
passiert in den letzten Jahren aber da
gibt's noch weiteres zu tun das ist
übrigens einer der Punkte wo man
tatsächlich sagen kann
da da können wir das Fördern und
übrigens die ganz ganz viele wollen das
ja auch die wollen ja gar nicht
rumsitzen Ihre Einrichtung und ein
weiteren Punkt das muss man sagen wenn
man jetzt die die Zahlen die ich auch
genannt habe die muss man aber natürlich
immer von Arbeitslosigkeit und offenen
Jobs die muss man immer vor dem
Hintergrund sehen dass es in Deutschland
passiert in Schleswig-Holstein in
Baden-Württemberg den ungeheuren Aufbau
an Beschäftigung den Wert trotzdem
hingekriegt haben wir werden noch mal
die Zahl sagen den letzten 20 Jahren
40.000 neue Jobs wir haben ja
ein Problem
völlig un dynamische Situation hat
sondern wir haben ja deutschlandweit
massenhaft Beschäftigung aufgebaut es
ist nicht so dass man sagt haben immer
weniger Leute Situationen
also
ja bin aber immer dafür eine sehr klare
Diagnose zu stellen die Diagnose müssen
bestellen da könnten wir jetzt auch
lange über Bildungspolitik und Schulen
und so weiter sprechen eine Frage noch
an sie hohe Matzen die Frage warum
machen sie das nicht so könnten sie
sagen in Schleswig-Holstein sind ja vor
einigen Frauen die aus der Ukraine
kommen die Männer sind wehrpflichtig
ihr müsst sofort in den Arbeitsmarkt
könnten sie das Ansagen anordnen oder
stehender bürokratische Hindernis naja
das ist das System nicht bedingt und ich
sag ja noch mal der Vorteil des
deutsches Systems ist der langfristige
Betrachtung dessen dass man Menschen mit
den Fähigkeiten die sich schon
mitbringen dann mit der deutschen
Kompetenz auch dort einsetzen können
also es ist eher dann statt Arbeitskraft
Fachkräfte die man damit gewinnt aber
die Diskussion hat auch immer ein
Problem weil über Fachkräfte Zuwanderung
und Flüchtlinge ein bisschen
durcheinander gebracht werden erstens
müssen wir ja für uns verstehen
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine sind Menschen
die vom Krieg geflüchtet sind also es
geht in erster Linie dass wir den
Sicherheit geben da kann es nicht in
erster Linie sein auch ist das schön die
Lösung unser Probleme hier da müssen wir
ganz anders strukturell dran aus meiner
Wahrnehmung anderseits muss ich sagen
nach 15 Monate indem ich in
schleswig-holsteinische unterwegs in den
Unternehmen jede Woche mehreren
Unternehmen habe ich immer gedacht wir
werden über Energiepreise diskutieren
das einzige was ich jedes Mal diskutiere
ist Fachkräfte genau das ist ein
Grundsatz ganz viele Unternehmen sagen
mit Klaus es läuft super aber wir müssen
Aufträge ablehnen richtig Fachkräfte und
die kriegen natürlich gleichzeitig
Diskussion mit wie die der Landrat haben
dass sehr viele Menschen hier sind und
sie aber Herren und sie sagen wir würden
wir nehmen jeden wir bringen uns ein wir
sind bereit mama Papa Onkel Tante zu
sein weil das ist ja auch die Wahrheit
an der Arbeitgeber der sagt ich möchte
gerne jemanden von außerhalb bei mir
aufnehmen muss ja mehr als einfach nur
Gehalt zahlen da muss ich den
Integration da ist Sportverein da ist
dass sich um den Menschen kümmern
wichtig für diesen Menschen zu sein und
das muss man auch abwägen ob man diese
Zeit hat als Unternehmen wenn man sie
nicht hat würde ich das abraten aber
ansonsten ist ja genau das diese
matching der nicht hin okay beides nicht
ne es gibt ja beides es gibt ja berichte
Frau von von dieser Tage von einem
Startup Unternehmen in Berlin gelesen
die wollten einen
aktiv-fachmann an Computer Crack an
jungen Typen ja und zwar ganz toll dir
zu sagen der am Computer was kann von
den Philippinen nach Deutschland holen
und schon nach acht Monaten war hier
das war relativ schwer
[Musik]
hätte ich gerne von dem glaube ich dass
er was kann und das wissen wir ungefähr
wie lange ein Flug von Manila bis nach
Berlin dauert ein Termin bei der
Botschaft
und das Problem weiter Einführung des
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetzes im Jahr
2020 sind 130.000 Fachkräfte mit einem
solchen Visum nach Deutschland gekommen
das ist quasi nichts also es wird
prognostiziert dass wir allein 400.000
Zuwanderer qualifizierte Zuwanderer
bräuchten um die Lücken hier auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt zu schließen weil Leute
genau wir haben ja Wanderung wir
brauchen die netto also das heißt noch
viel mehr also von daher zeigt das
welche Hürden da sind und da schließt
sich auch so ein bisschen der Kreis zu
dem worüber wir am Anfang Sprachen ja es
wurde jetzt nachgeschärft also es wird
jetzt das Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
wurde er reformiert aber letztlich
machen wir wieder das was wir besonders
gut können nämlich wir setzen jetzt noch
mal eine bürokratische Ebene drauf das
gibt jetzt diese chancenkarte wo dann
verschiedene Ebenen sind
Sprachkenntnisse Alter welche berufliche
Qualifikation hat jemand aber das muss
ja auch wiederum jemand ausfüllen und
begutachten und bewerten und also da ist
ja auch durchaus in der Politik eine
große Sorge da dass das zwar in Berlin
alles schön erdacht wurde aber das dann
ein großes Problem wird dass dann in den
ausländerämtern in Bremen und überall im
Land zum Beispiel genau das ist nämlich
genau das Thema da wird in Berlin sich
was überlegt und sie haben es dann
umzusetzen wir haben vorhin schon das
Thema Bürokratie Monster aufgebaut die
können jetzt abendfüllen darüber
berichten über bthg was es an Mehrkosten
also ein ganz anderer Baustelle aber man
kann unendlich fortsetzen und da hat die
Falle vorhin schon richtig gesagt man
muss aufpassen dass man von oben also
Demokratie fängt unten an in den Städten
und Gemeinden miteinander miteinander
gepflegt die Gemeinden diese zuständig
vom Kindergarten bis zu erklären von
Friedhof so
viele Dinge dieses die Menschen direkt
betreffen ja die Landkreis übernimmt
dann die Aufgaben die die
Gemeinschaft schaffen also mir haben ein
gut funktionierendes
Prinzip mal aufgebaut was auch die
Demokratie stärkt und jetzt erleben wir
halt zunehmend dass das Stück weit in
Berlin
meine Landesregierung oder Landespolitik
die Dinge so vorgekaut werden dass wir
unten gar nicht mehr das schaffen können
wir haben übrigens Fachkräftemangel auch
auf kommunaler Ebene mittlerweile ja
also wir kommen da gar nicht nach allen
Ansprüchen oder im anspruchserwartungen
die
geweckt werden fahrlässig geweckt werden
in Koalitionsverträgen auftauchen oder
wo auch immer dass sie in der Umsetzung
gar nicht mehr gehindert werden können
das Thema Flüchtlinge aufgreifen dann
sind wir aber noch ganz kurz
zusammenfassen diese vollkas
kommentarität die kann sich dieser Staat
nicht mehr leicht wir müssen wieder den
Menschen Mut machen auch den Städten und
Gemeinden die Chance geben die
Beinfreiheit geben dass sie eben auch
eigenverantwortlich für die Aufgaben
wurde verantwortlich sind oder sie
Unterbringen von Menschen sind oder
andere mehr dann auch genügend
Kreativität und Vielfalt
bedarfsorientiert in einzelnen Städten
und Gemeinden dann auch
anhängen darf weil wir gerade Ukraine
gesprochen haben ich habe eine
atemberaubende Zahl gelesen die wir
haben sowieso nicht klar ich habe dieser
Tage gehört von Menschen den besagten
naja wir haben deutlich erkennbar eine
Bewegung von Polen nach Deutschland also
auch Polen ist ein sicheres Land und
viele
Ukrainerinnen vor allen Dingen haben
Schutz gefunden in Polen ist eine
großartige Leistung die die da
vollbracht haben aber jetzt gibt es eine
Bewegung nach Deutschland
umgekehrt gibt es auch eine Bewegung von
Frankreich nach Deutschland und allein
Irland Baden-Württemberg hat doppelt so
viele Ukraine wie Frankreich aufgenommen
wie kann das sein was ist ihre Erklärung
dafür sind gute informiert also
tatsächlich Baden-Württemberg Zeit
Kriegsausbruch 175 000
Menschen also Ukraine erhalten für die
wir dann sorge tragen wir haben selber
und im Landkreisen ehemaligen Kaserne
auch ein ankunftszentrum gemeinsam mit
dem Land Baden-Württemberg errichtet ist
sehr gut funktioniert wo wir eben auch
hautnah diese Geschichten die sie gerade
gesagt haben auch mitbekommen
Frank ganz Frankreich selber hat 70.000
30.000 Frankreich Baden-Württemberg
170.000 oder 160.000 aber so in der
Größenordnung und Grund ist sicherlich
auch der rechtspreis rechts Kreis
Wechsel der damals beschlossen worden
ist um die Menschen schnell in Arbeit zu
bringen der Gedanke war zunächst mal gut
aber dieser Rechtskreis Wechsel der dann
in Berlin beschlossen worden ist hat
eben zur Folge dass unsere Jobcenter
plötzlich alle Hände voll zu tun hatten
noch gar nicht drauf vorbereitet waren
diese rechtsreißwechsel der dann den Job
sondern bearbeiten muss
nebenbei bemerkt die Bundesagentur die
Gemeinde mit unseres Jobcenter betreibt
die hatte nicht mehr Mitarbeiter zur
Verfügung aber wir hatten alle Hände
voll zu tun insbesondere auch weil wir
das ankunftszentrum hatten und da eben
auch noch mehr Belastung haben alles auf
kommunalen Rücken ausgetragen ja diese
rechtsreifswechsel hat die fatale
Auswirkung das tatsächlich auch Menschen
die in Polen in Sicherheit waren die die
Stadt schon Arbeitsplätze hat die mit
den Familien in Sicherheit aus dem
Kriegsgebiet gefüttert sind ein
Familienvater Lohn und Brot 300 €
verdient kommt er zu uns mit Kindern
bekamer halt 1500 €. 300 € für Arbeiten
in Polen und 1500 € und 1500 bei uns
andersrum wir hatten sehr kreativ wenn
die Menschen stellen Arbeiten bringen
wollten haben wir schnell
Veranstaltungen durchgeführt wo Firmen
wo
Produktionsbetriebe aber auch zum
Beispiel unsere Klinikum auch in
ukrainischer Heimatsprache geworden
haben um die Menschen gleich mit ihre
Qualifikation
Sprachkurse parallel ähnlich wie das in
Dänemark funktioniert
auch hier anzubieten wenn halt dann ein
Arbeitgeber
1600 Euro bereit ist zu bezahlen für
einen angelernt oder ungelernten und
nicht deutsch sprechenden Mitarbeiter
aber das Jobcenter 1500 bezahlt und
wo dann Arbeitsplatz hat auf sein
Wohngeld oder die die Wohnung und die
Heizung die kommt beim Bürgergeld eben
irgendwie dazu dann brauchen wir nicht
lange überlegen wofür der sich
entscheidet und das waren gab es dann
auch enttäusche Gesichter bei
Arbeitgebern die sich wirklich
die hilfsbereit angepackt haben die
Lösung gesucht haben für uns die uns
helfen wollten die dann plötzlich allein
gelassen worden sind also diese
rechtskreiswechsel hat gut gedacht aber
in der Auswirkung fatale Sogwirkung in
Europa für die Kriegsflüchtlinge die
eben nicht europaweit sich dann
verteilen ließen sondern okay dann bei
uns gelandet sind und das ist eben auch
was was die Menschen ein Stück weit
mitbekommen und wo auch dann eben dieses
steht Unruhe auch dieser Tage auch viel
hier über über die über die Wut die so
im Land zu spüren haben sie das Thema
auch wo man es ist ist das Thema falsche
Anreize oder was ist das Thema naja also
ich glaube wir haben das generell in
Deutschland aber das man muss nochmals
glaube ich ein bisschen aufpassen dass
wir nicht alle Themen damit einander
vermischen da ist in Deutschland eine
wahnsinnige hohe Hilfsbereitschaft da
sind überall in vielen Gemeinden
großartige Veranstaltungen gemacht
worden Familien sind integriert worden
aber wir müssen natürlich auch aufpassen
dass wir nicht in einzelne Regionen eine
Überlastung bekommen dass wir die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Teilen
überlassen und dass man auch man muss ja
auch ein Ausweg ein Stück weiter kennen
wie soll das Ganze weitergehen von einen
anfänglichen immer großzügige Umgang
muss man ja irgendwann auch hinkommen zu
wie soll das System tragfähig bleiben
und da kann ich ein bisschen das mit
unterstützen dass wenn das Thema
Bürgergeld ist ein wunderbares und
Menschen zu unterstützen die wirklich
Unterstützung brauchen aber wir haben ja
auch nach wie vor sehr viele Menschen
die auch was leisten können und ich
glaube dass diese Leistungsgedanke noch
stärker nach vorne ist muss sich lohnen
zu arbeiten es kann ja nicht sein jemand
setzt sich im Bus fährt im Bus und hat
das Gefühl er hat ein steht schlechter
als sein Nachbar der vielleicht nicht zu
Arbeit geht oder in der Werkhalle
sondern das Gefühl muss sein ich bin
Teil der Lösung ich trage Verantwortung
und ich werde dafür auch wertgeschätzt
und kriege einen anständiges gehalten
und wenn jemand sagt dass ich mache da
nicht mit dann muss es auf jeden Fall
ein signifikanter Unterschied sein ist
muss sich lohnend zu arbeiten und das
ist ein großes strukturelles Problem
deswegen ich glaube dass wir das überall
im Moment spüren eine hohe
Unzufriedenheit aber das ist natürlich
auch viel getrieben durch Diskussionen
wie ist denn wirklich dann der Zustand
aber letztendlich ja es muss weil das
ist ja auch das was ich den Firmen
erklären muss die dahinter hängt Leute
brauchen der ist schon dass die
Mitarbeiter dann auch kommen das stimmt
deshalb war es ja auch so fatal dem
Mindestlohn um 3,4% anzuregen obwohl die
Inflation viel viel höher war das hat
tatsächlich den Anreiz dass es sich
lohnt zu arbeiten nicht wirklich gut
getan sondern machen sie das hätte man
den Mindestlohn deutlich anheben sehr
weil die Frage ist sozusagen das stimmt
es muss sich lohnen zu arbeiten die
Frage ist wie kriegt man das hin manche
sagen da sehen wir als Problem
diejenigen die Bürger Geld beziehen und
andere sagen das Problem ist dass die
Löhne die gezahlt werden nicht
ausreichend sei es der Mindestlohn oder
sei es auch die dann spielen wir auf
ungute Leute
gegeneinander wissen dass die realöhne
in Deutschland jetzt drei Prozent
unterhalb des vorpandemie-niveaus liegt
genau also das heißt die Leute haben
und so gleichzeitig und müssen dann auch
mal sagen sind die Gewinner deutlich
angestiegen liegen deutlich oberhalb des
Niveaus von 2019 aber wenn wir sozusagen
eine mindestlohnerhöhung haben die die
inflationsverluste nicht wegmacht wenn
wir eine Senkung von Real lohnen haben
dann ist das aus meiner Sicht das
zentrale Problem und nicht das
Bürgergeld
das Bürgergeld ist vor einem Jahr um
knapp zwölf Prozent erhöht worden zum
nächsten Beginn also zu Beginn 2024 wird
es jetzt noch mal um 12 % erhöht diese
Rechenbeispiel das eine fünfköpfige
Familie ungefähr auf 3000 Euro mit
Bürgergeld und den ganzen Wohnkosten
kommt der Durchschnittslohn in
Deutschland beträgt 4.1 Euro also das
ist da ist viel zu wenig Abstand drin
und ich finde es interessant
anfangen sondern und nicht unten beim
Bürgergeld tatsächlich anfangen also es
gibt ja in der SPD viele die sagen das
ist noch viel zu niedrig obwohl es jetzt
schon so stark gestiegen ist ich glaube
sie bekommen das irgendwann nicht mehr
erklärt warum das Bürgergeld so viel
stärker sein muss
deckt das Existenzminimum ab und wenn es
eine starke Kostenentwicklung gibt weil
das massiven Anstieg der Kosten für
Lebensmittel gibt und für alle anderen
Dinge die lebensnotwendig sind dann ist
es ganz klar aus der Berechnung dass
dann das Existenzminimum
angehoben werden muss und es ist ja auch
sichergestellt dass man immer wenn man
arbeitet mehr hat als wenn man Bürger
geht kriegt das ist ja gesehen
nicht aber noch entscheidend
wenn derjenige der Arbeit damit auch
noch zusätzlich
Aufstockung beantragt
aber auch genau ich wollte noch fragen
was ist das für ein Mensch ich wollte
noch mal ich wollte noch mal jemanden
der von morgens bis abends arbeitet
um irgendwelche Zuschauer was ist das
für ein Menschenbild das eine
mindestlohnkommission in Zeiten
zweistellige Inflationsraten im
Mindestlohn um 3,4 % erhöht was ist das
für Menschenbild
möchte zumindestens sagen das ist der
zweithöchste Mindestlohn in Europa also
gesetzliche Mindestlohn daher wir müssen
auch vielleicht wenn wir immer wir
vergleichen uns mit diesen europäischen
Vergleich diesen und jenen und wenn wir
dann zu dem Ergebnis kommen wir haben
schon mal den zweithöchsten
mindestlohngesetzlich in Europa ist das
ja nicht ganz daneben wenn man den
Mindestlohn hat und man erhöht ihn
unterhalb der Inflation der ich bleib ja
das kann ich ganz gut verstehen ja
Moment aber es wäre auch gut wenn es ein
Anreiz geben dass ich arbeiten gehe und
dass ich mich weiter qualifiziere und
dass ich hochwertige Arbeit bekommen der
Mindestlohn ist ja ein vom gesetzgebende
der dann einen eine Stufenmodell in den
Betrieben aber dazu führt dass der ein
oder andere sich Mitarbeiter nicht mehr
leisten kann